karim has developed a new method for
measuring cholesterol level that doesn't
involve any invasive procedure like
drawing blood that would be very nice
regulations demand that the test should
be correct 99 of the time
tests should be correct 99 of the time
so he had to verify that his method
meets the standards
he got a random sample of 100 people
tested their cholesterol using his new
method compared the results to blood
tests performed on the same people and
found they were the same 95 percent of
the time
since blood tests are always correct he
concluded that his method was correct 95
percent of the time
that seems reasonable at least for his
sample right over here in light of the
results karim had to test the hypothesis
that the test is in fact correct 99 of
the time so he wanted to test the
hypothesis that the test is in fact
correct 99 percent of the time
so he performed 100 computer generated
simulations of random samples of a
hundred tests so there's a lot of
hundreds here so he did a hundred
simulations and each of those samples
essentially simulated the test results
of a hundred people so it's like using a
computer that assumes this assumption
that assumes that the test is in fact
correct 99 of the time and to simulate a
hundred of these of these of these
samples these 100 samples each of them
having 100 people in them
supposing the true percentage of correct
result is 99
to find how likely it is that a sample
would have a 95 percent would have 95
correct results the results of the
simulations are plotted below
how do the results of the simulations
affect the likelihood of the hypothesis
that kareem's test is correct 99 of the
time so i know this can be a little bit
confusing because we have all of these
we're testing and
and hundreds and all of this but what
he's doing he's like okay he got his
test
on this one sample his test was right 95
of the time
but what he wants to really figure out
is he wants to get a sense of what's the
probability of that happening
assuming that his test is actually
correct 99 of the time
so he has the hypothesis so if we
assumed the hypothesis if you assumed
if you assumed his test
his test
his test correct
correct
99 of the time so that's the hypothesis
right over here
then if we assume this he's trying to
figure out what's the probability that
he gets these results
what
is
probability
probability of
this right over here
because if this probability is really
low if the probability of getting this
is really low
then he could say well then i can't make
that then i really i really don't feel
good about assuming this hypothesis that
maybe we we can't go with the hypothesis
if the probability of this is hap of
this of the if the probability of him
seeing what he saw is very low given
this assumption
so let's look at that
so let's interpret what's happening in
this chart here so remember the computer
is running a hundred a hundred
it's it's simulating a hundred
samples each of those samples have a
hundred people so for each sample so let
me make it clear so this is sample one
so sample
sample number one and then there would
be sample number two and there's going
to be there's going to be a hundred of
these samples each of these samples the
computer is saying okay for and there's
a hundred people in each sample one two
three and it goes all the way to the
hundredth
all the way to the 100th person for each
of these the computer's saying okay i'm
assuming there's a 99 chance that's
correct so the computer uses its random
number generator it's essentially kind
of trying to roll the dice and 99 out of
100 times it'll say the sample is the
the new test matches up to the old test
but then every now and then there's that
one percent chance that it says okay
it doesn't match up so let's say that
this one had 99 checks and then one x
then this would fall into this category
right over here then this sample
this sample right over here would
correspond let me do this in a color so
this sample right of i mean a new color
so this sample right over here
would correlate to say
this dot
and then if they did the test again and
maybe it got 99 checks and one x then it
would be say number two so it would be
there
let's say in one of the samples
let's say in one of the the the samples
of a hundred
i guess
virtual people right over here it got it
you know there's a 99 chance of getting
a check here so they it got all it got
all hundred people got a check then that
would be
then it would stack it up right over
here
and so we see using the assumption that
there's a 99
chance of the test matching up or
there's a 99 chance that the test is
correct
it got all of these results and we see
that out of these hundred samples it
took
none of them
none of them gave
what kareem observed right over here
so it seems like if you make this
assumption the probability of observing
what he observed right over here seems
very very very very low
so this this to me or i guess to any
reasonable statistician or reasonable
person
these results the results he got the
results that he both observed and the
results of the simulation
tells us that the likelihood of the
the likelihood of the hypothesis being
correct
is low
so this is a the likelihood of the
hypothesis that kareem's test is 99
that creams test is correct 99 of the
time the likelihood of this hypothesis
is very low
very
very low given this observation and the
results of the simulation
and so you'd be likely to reject the
hypothesis